hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley baby here we go one more
time on a friday hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is are you garbage the show where
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and find if they go up classy or if
they're garbagio
i'm a trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day here in the east village
here
gas digital studios in the big studio
family operation
couldn't be more excited feels great in
here around the holidays i got to tell
you that with halloween coming up
i'm excited my co-host coming at you
from right next to me
making weird eyes at me all right trying
to show me look who calls halloween the
holidays that's right it is what starts
right now baby we're going until january
i'll tell you that and i'll throw in
valentine's day there too so what about
that
okay kevin james ryan everybody hey
what's up everybody uh thanks so much
for listening as always please make sure
you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube you can subscribe there as
well
and if you want to sign up for gas
digital network you get our full catalog
of like i don't even it's like 40 some
episodes at this point i don't know what
it is i don't even know what number
we're at plus the entire gas digital
plus the entire
plus the entire gas digital catalog but
for our episodes you'll get andrew
schultz
you'll get [ __ ] mark norman joe list
ari shafir
who else we got gillis is back everybody
the [ __ ] louis j gomez you got
everybody kim cogdon kim cogden so you
can go sign up use promo code ayg
you save a couple of bucks every month
we make a couple of bucks every month
the kids wet their beaks it's a win
[ __ ] win cage small bills
baby small bills i want to be paid in
ones this month mr gomez
paid in ones unmarked bills and gang
today we have an incredibly special
treat for you guys
probably the most requested uh guest
here on the podcast she's a part of the
gas digital family
one of the most well respected and
talented producers here at the network
she is the producer of real ass podcasts
with louis shea gomez
also produces sex drugs and rock and
roll with mr ralph sutton
and mr big j okerson and is the producer
of no disrespect with mr vike becky own
and is the host of her very own podcast
called the thing is
but the big question in everybody's mind
today is she garbage
i got the middle name so it's not
looking good
off the job i'm leaning towards you yeah
ladies and gentlemen give me a nice big
round of applause for the one the only
shannon lee everybody
what's up guys thanks for doing the show
thank you buddy
thank you i uh do you think you're
garbage
[Laughter]
i think there are moments of garbage
okay and
overall i might be split down the middle
i'm guessing coming from garbage
but we're going to get into it yeah i'm
curious
good kind of i'm curious to know what
the verdict is going to be actually i
did i did because
i did some research last night i was
poking around on facebook there's a
couple of pics on facebook that aren't
the classic
facebook what are you doing i'm snooping
i'm going wait for my 20s
holy where did you grow up tell us that
story so i grew up in bensonhurst
brooklyn
okay i think you're a staten island girl
you live in staten island now i live in
that island now yeah
okay that's the migration of people that
start out in bensonhurst then sun island
then new jersey
did you make it to staten island i am in
central now yeah okay
you're planning to go to jersey wait no
hold on did your family move from
bensonhurst to staten island yes okay
all right
that's the my that's like we we made it
out of bensonhurst we're going to the
island yeah
and everyone like buys their houses on
the island and then i guess they upgrade
to a bigger house in jersey
no one from my family's really made it
to jersey yet
there's a kind of in a holding pattern
now families are always rising and
falling in america
yeah well that is because we're you know
from philly so we there's the similar
thing is to
if you you grow up in one of the
neighborhoods you get a couple of bucks
and you move to south jersey
that's like the thing is you can get a
single family home with a yard a garage
type thing
so it's the same same migration yeah
bensonhurst that's way more old school
than i thought i was thinking small town
jersey across the bridge
oh no no no bensonhurst yeah that's like
that's some tough [ __ ] that's saturday
night fever yes exactly that yeah it was
like very
like all italian you know i think in my
in my elementary school there were i
remember there were two black children
and they were twins and their names were
trevor and travis i remember this so
much because those were the only
black people that i saw until i went to
high school wow was that like that
hardcore italian yeah wow
catholic school no no no well always
public school wow
interesting they brothers and sisters i
have a little sister she's six and a
half years younger than me
okay so you were kind of on your own
more or less right yeah for a while
and mom and dad still together what did
they do
okay so oh the fed's listening cut
the wire bill cut it
are you are you familiar with the title
anytime in italian anytime you ask an
italian girl what her parents do and she
goes well here's the name
are you familiar with interstate
trucking at all
do you know anybody that has a weigh
station do you know the ricoh statue
uh so when i was like a small child my
mom was a stay-at-home mom
and my dad worked like on a trading
floor
okay in like wall street okay um and
then
on the new york exchange yeah but like
not not actually it's not like wall
street
proper it was in a um
what are you talking about stop trying
to talk this
did you ever hear of a shell corporation
it was in the back of a pork store
but they wore suits the name of the
company back then was banker's trust i
believe it's deutsche bank now
but he worked for that deutsche bank
deutsche bank it used to be banker's
trust is this i don't know
yeah oh that sounds about right that
sounds legit yeah but deutsche bank was
in bed with [ __ ] epstein they're not
on the up and up
damn it they're the ones that like they
were giving all the money to epstein
and they're like what were you doing
yeah yeah who knows yeah
i got a bad connection so my dad my dad
worked there for a while
and then he had um he got up to like an
executive level at one point
so we had like money so but my dad was
never home because he was always working
but we had like we're very comfortable
okay until he got into like a
disagreement with his partners there
and then he quit and then he was kind of
doing stuff he actually did like video
editing for a while and then he just
became like an entrepreneur
okay during that period of time the
money like went from one extreme to the
other
yeah so um so during that period of time
my mother started waitressing
at a diner okay in the neighborhood this
isn't bensonhurst
yeah oh i bet that was a good diner it
was a great diner
and were you guys in an apartment or did
you have a house so it was a two-family
private house and we lived on the top
floor gotcha that's old school that's it
yeah that's old school new york two
family private house
floor and then when you got to staten
island okay so where are we at in the
in in the lineage of uh when your dad
stopped
when the money went to the extreme were
you already in staten island at that
time no i
i moved to staten island seven years ago
okay as like er
on my own all right yeah so i lived in
brooklyn forever okay but you said your
parents are in staten island now too
yeah also like eight or nine years ago
okay just all recently yeah all right so
when the downturn happened it
kind of stayed that way for a while yeah
okay all right
very interesting and i got to say
something my brother worked on wall
street and he worked with did you
go to school did he go to college i
don't know school the hard knocks
you know what i mean we'll see there's
two kinds of traitors down there it
might be different now but they're the
guys that went to [ __ ] school the
younger guys
but then there's dudes probably like her
dad that were [ __ ] animals down there
that [ __ ]
only had a high school diploma yeah yeah
they're the ones that [ __ ] racked it
in
i don't think my dad i believe he had a
ged
because he went he went to the army
that's where my parents met actually
they met in the army yeah your mom was
in the army as well
damn yeah they met i believe they were
like 19 and 21 were their ages
and like my dad left to just like get
out of brooklyn my mom left to get out
of maine
and uh yeah they met the army and they
married after three months and they're
still together
yeah 40 years later that's [ __ ]
awesome
was he was he in any wars or anything
like that
no okay no all right all right a couple
domestics
[Laughter]
that was later on
i was like brace it for something the
way you said that and you were like all
right
hold on no no no no it's that seems
pretty clean and that's all
on the normal normal upbringing you feel
yes yeah despite what people peg on me
for
my choices later on in life it didn't
come from family things okay so that's
that's well that's what we've
found out by doing this it's like
there's a point some people are just
born into trash
and they stay trash some people are born
into trash and they you know
overcome again i'm not gonna be where my
dirtbag family is other people
are born into nice families and stuff
like that then once they start making
the decisions
it takes a hard left how are you doing
nice to meet you
you're right your parents are going your
parents are [ __ ] dirt balls
they're watching this i love you pop um
i'll get that 20 back to you as soon as
i got it i promise you
um what were the decisions that you made
later oh i don't
i just i think it was maybe i dated some
pretty shitty
guys that okay well this is this is if
you know
especially on gas digital we're gonna
get her on the love life
is very known it's part of you know your
personality and stuff like that your you
know your on-air personality
uh and you have a very specific kind of
guy you like to date yeah and you
describe
them as what um scary looking
[Laughter]
she likes guys to crack heads yeah or at
least have the ability to
but have the maturity and the
intelligence to not
unless needed wow have you ever
witnessed your boyfriend i've never felt
like such a [ __ ] about like
god i wanna she goes i want a guy who
can [ __ ]
people up but he doesn't do it because
he's a good guy you know he comes from a
good family loves his mother
exactly have you ever seen one of your
boyfriend straighten somebody out in
front of you yes oh
man what's that like that's real italian
garbage
tony get back in the car johnny it ain't
worth it
i love you have you ever screamed that
like hey fight you know
um kind of it's just i did i'm sorry did
you have vollis a relationship with some
of these guys was there like fighting on
the street and stuff like that yelling
at each other
um i would love to see yeah these dudes
aren't calm cool collectors
she's dating they're [ __ ] gorilla
love me
uh yeah the last time i saw a boyfriend
uh put his hands on somebody
it was kind of warranted that's like old
mob
[ __ ] well he he shouldn't have been
[ __ ] standing [ __ ]
lucky luciano over here put his hands on
a guy that's a real technical that
that's not that that's such a selective
wording just
he didn't hit him he didn't assault him
in case anybody's list he put his hands
on him talking to james khan ladies and
gentlemen
he definitely had a leather jacket on a
nice leather too he may have yet friday
night you're out trying to have a nice
night driving a nice night my [ __ ]
girl over here you causing [ __ ]
problems
it's so close to what happened tell the
story
lay it on us lay in here you two are
spimoni gardens with a plate of mussels
in front of you
huh no we're actually at a place called
the marina cafe
in staten island okay and uh we were
there celebrating his brother's birthday
so his dad was out
and like a bunch of their friends were
out and everyone's already charged up oh
[ __ ] squad that's also that's a real
trash thing to when like
when you feel they've ruined a family
event you know it's my [ __ ] brother's
birthday
you pull this [ __ ] i come out for a nice
thing it's my brother's [ __ ] birthday
so this guy this guy who i believe was
like an ex-football
player i don't remember i don't know
what to do was he in the party was he at
the party with you
he was he was at the place professional
that football player my big any time
there's like i'm after dinner or
something like that and there's like a
big
party of like tough dudes or whatever
you know they're always looking to [ __ ]
somebody else yeah make an example
i'm not looking out there to donate to
charity yeah some guy at the bar running
his mouth or god forbid they [ __ ] hit
on one of their girls or something like
that
well that's very clear okay here we go
so the football player i don't even have
to be here you guys could tell my whole
story
wait was he a current football player no
he was an ex-football player oh
professional
yeah okay so he uh he like because you
know i played a little bit
soccer it was the goal
so he put his arm around my ex's
brother's girlfriend or whatever
why how are you mixing we just so the
dinner's over you're mixing mingling at
the bar a little bit people are getting
familiar but they don't realize they're
dealing with [ __ ]
see but in staten island it's like every
[ __ ] meathead from fencers
that don't have a goddamn future oh my
god would you put your arm around this
girl what
what the [ __ ] hello ma'am yesterday i'm
sorry we keep going it's okay
so they they knew it like they knew each
other because in state island same thing
like bensonhurst everyone knows each
other
so they knew him from somewhere before
and um so
he did that and then he as as
my ex's brother is talking to him the
guy likes
sucker punched him from the side in a
weird way and they're walking in front
of us and my ex and i are here
so when my ex sees that this is his
little brother so he now i know
so there was an exchange once once the
uh once the penalty
happened once the guy put the arm around
the girlfriend there was obviously an
exchange between those like
let's let's like they talked about it
but away from the bar
so pulled him aside yeah holy [ __ ] it's
a real wise guy
absolutely somebody was like hey can i
talk to you for a second there's no way
please i think i i'm gonna pick up a
shift i'm gonna start working here i'm
never leaving this
that's the guy that doesn't want to make
a scene that's the one you got to be
scared of
yeah so yeah so the guy hit him when my
ex saw that the guy hit his brother
he like went after that guy and then it
was like a whole
tussle he's like on top of the guy on
the ground in the parking lot it was a
whole thing
and now but i you know as much as i like
somebody's ability to do this when it
happens i still
panic yeah i'm like i don't want anybody
hurt like this isn't that type of like
no one needs to actually be heard over
something so stupid
but a little party liked it it fires you
up a little bit
no knowing that like because like the
guy i'm getting turned down
he still got his number what's happening
i want to see a picture of this boa
mike what are you from the 30s
bow hunk i don't even know what that
means i don't know it's bringing
feelings out of me
i don't know what's going on i tell you
what fat kids always
can i get a white wine in here by the
way please thank you all right so my ex
didn't have like a single scratch on him
just some like blood on his shoes from
the other guy
oh dude what the [ __ ] i was about to ask
you what'd you guys have for dessert
holy [ __ ] so yeah that's all that that
also shows how much she liked
he didn't have a scratch on him yeah but
the other you should have seen the other
guy yeah i thought it was terrible i
don't believe
in that but he [ __ ] this guy up he
even got him coming he didn't even get a
shot in on him
he didn't yeah see that's that's a
that's a point of pride did you clean
the blood off the shoes that night
i did on your nose
[Music]
oh my yeah please
it's not the first or last time that
i've iced a guy's knuckles
ice and knuckles what the [ __ ] what holy
[ __ ]
my girlfriend painted my toenails last
weekend
i used my knuckles that's insane
should i go now 15-minute episode
everybody
wow juicy um and what about you as far
as your trajectory to becoming a
producer here at gas
what did you go to college um i went to
a little bit of college i went to like
uh i think
like a semester and a half at cw post
long island university
dude this is all checking out these are
like the boxes on this they're just
going
right down the line was it was there was
there any uh beautician school involved
no no no okay no no dental hygienist
nope all right none of that phlebotomy
lobotomy is a big i just don't know what
it is i'm gonna be a phlebotomist what
about like chiropractor a trainer
all right all right here we go i'll give
you i'll give you the ones that will
check off more boxes so i did
time shares in florida i did go to um
the scratch academy to learn to be a dj
what year was this how's their football
team
it was hold on did you take out did you
take out financial aid to go to this
no i had a buddy dude i had a buddy take
out like [ __ ] 35 grand to go to like
ch or something
to do some sort of skill that he's never
yeah i'm like what
is this in bensonhurst uh no the school
was here in the city but i was living in
ben's nurse at the time
that's also a big thing for like deep
brooklyn and queen of the city
it's a big separation between
the city manhattan and like what you
call this this is like yeah
it's very separate you're old guard
brooklyn that's right you're old [ __ ]
guard she's old school
old school bro yeah i wasn't allowed to
take the train into the city by myself
until i was 18.
okay wow yeah but yeah i also because
there are animals in there
now robbie in there i also went to
school to become a personal trainer so i
had an
asm accreditation okay um i went to real
estate school for a short period of time
that's everything that's every
knucklehead every knucklehead from a
neighborhood like that in any city
across the country specifically boston
to philadelphia do you know how many
cousins how many how many of my cousins
have their real estate license
they don't they don't even own property
ah dude it looks like like 10 years ago
they were like everybody yeah yeah i
mean making money hand over fist he got
his money
they got to pay they got to pay the
broker's fee oh dude that's
[ __ ] great all right real estate did
you did you work in real estate for a
little while no i never finished taking
the classes
once it got to the math i'm like i'm out
10
what the [ __ ] you mean
[Laughter]
how i got into podcasting was eight
years ago
um when i was like when i was dating
still um i would always go to work
because i always worked in like
corporate life
and uh i would go in and tell my bad
date stories and like oh you should
write a book and whatever because i had
the worst dates
and it was the time that podcasts were
like starting so i was like i'm not
going to write a book but maybe i'll
start a podcast
okay and so i've been doing my podcast
for eight years
and then um the thing is has been going
on for eight years that's [ __ ]
awesome
what's that you always do ding that's
the thing it's something that's grown
because it's something that people will
say throughout the course of the show we
have to like acknowledge it and then it
just became
the thing is the thing yeah i had such a
fun time with sean patton
on that it was great i feel like you
both got freaked out when you were both
on
the show with the ghost stories yeah
patton freaked me out with this ghost
story that was a great episode
he's also trash because it starts in the
woods which we said to him last week
when he was on the podcast
what his ghost story i told you sean
patton starts out with him and his buddy
in the woods drinking well the girl
the the the woman i did was like an
actress from i forgot what it was
um uh crazy crazy ex-girlfriend
and she was like yeah my uncle built a
house on a pet cemetery i'm like well
why the [ __ ] is staying in the house
lady
what the [ __ ] it was like a witch or
something yeah she's like oh it was
buried on an old witch burial i'm like
[ __ ] i'd move states if that i
wouldn't stay in a short house if the
grandfather died next door what are you
talking about
a pet cemetery yeah it was something
weird and i was like i was nervous we
did it remotely i was nervous in my
apartment because it was dark out my
wife wasn't
my one cousins lived next to a cemetery
and they did well
that used to blow my mind you got a
little bit of gage what are we doing
here
having thanksgiving looking at a [ __ ]
ichabod crane in the mist
get the [ __ ] out of here hey the
headless horseman wants seconds okay
[Music]
where'd you get the pumpkin for this all
right
oh my god jesus shannon
the fact that you vice down multiple
dude's knuckles is insane to me
was the so i'm not familiar with
straight so for
you don't really date now right you've
kind of calmed down like two and a half
years or something yeah two years and
seven months
i haven't had sex but okay um same with
bowling
i don't see what the biggest thing is
this isn't by choice though i don't see
what the big deal is nor do i uh realize
why you brought it up to be honest with
you um
what's so are behind that what what's
the personal choice of that because for
the
for the audio listener she's a knockout
she was running around with gorillas
what do you mean somebody's gonna get
[ __ ] hurt
that's why she's doing it for the good
of society can't ever out there on the
streets with these
me guys um i think just after
the breakup with that guy that i told
that story about ice knuckles
yeah okay um it was about um
we broke up maybe nine years ago and we
did some on again off again since we
broke up but ever since that breakup i
haven't been in like another real
relationship
since then and now i just i don't know
where to meet i don't know where to meet
people like i can't meet people here
yeah you know so i don't really know
where and plus there's no [ __ ] juice
heads coming in and out of gasoline
you got dylan who's 110 pounds soaking
wet he's not checking any boxes we need
a garage or a horse betting podcast
yeah is there an otp in the east village
that's a great idea
what can i say what did what did your
last boyfriend do let me guess
hold on no was it are we gonna be able
to guess it is it something standard
i got three guesses i go ahead go ahead
yeah mechanic
oh oh do you for work okay yeah no no
okay all right no that's not mine i was
gonna
what did you think we meant what did he
do that made me break up with him is the
after hours it's like i'm watching a
soap
i [ __ ] love this this is great um
i'm gonna go with the three
stereotypical new york
okay policeman firefighter or like
you know there was definitely a blue
collar union
union guy close what was it a
corrections officer
oh all right in the wheelhouse baby holy
[ __ ] a shot
good bunnies good pension i'd do 30
years i'm out
twenty years twenty years twenty years
i'm out i can retire forty four i'm
gonna be doing fishing charters in boca
this time next spring by that point
we'll have a house in [ __ ]
englewood new jersey or whatever he's
like he has retired now
okay he's retired uh yeah yeah whatever
did his full 20 now i think he was like
like six months short or something
because he had so many injuries
from took like an early year or
something yeah wait so many interviews
from what
uses the force oh you are correct
jesus christ you are garbage that's not
me
i know but the way you say it uses of
she will he put hands on him uses a
force he's cracking skulls you know
wives can't testify
the first thing she says
oh that's real this is like mob wives
garbage
oh holy crap he works at rikers for 12
years
sounds like a nice guy i didn't think he
i didn't think he was [ __ ] working
you know
probably not a big lunchables guy
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] damn this dude would [ __ ] us
up oh
man there's something i i loved
characters like that like
oh he just checks all it's so funny and
you're
you have such a fitness you have an
attraction to that kind of guy
yeah which is great that's [ __ ]
that's
yeah what was the fight oh that broke
out yeah let's do this now okay
so here we go so i worked um
for in like a you know a corporate
business at the time and i had to go
tax attorney got tuned up at the office
on a tuesday
probably deserved it i'll tell you that
she can wear whatever the [ __ ] she wants
jerk
have you ever said these words if i tell
my boyfriend this he'll kill you
yeah ah he got his [ __ ] hands all
over me i go to the [ __ ] checkout
so i was going on a business trip to
colorado
with a co-worker of mine the co-worker
was a guy he probably hated the [ __ ]
guys in that office
yeah but he didn't no it's like those
guys are probably [ __ ] dicks they're
probably scumbags hitting on you being
like that [ __ ]
but it wasn't it wasn't at all that way
but maybe that's what he was thinking in
his mind
and uh he didn't even know he's a former
psycho that's what he was thinking as a
guy yeah
any guy thinks that or assumes that let
alone a [ __ ] co in rikers
he's definitely thinking the worst he
probably ran the guy's plates
he probably knew some info about that
guy that guy wouldn't want people
knowing
all right so uh so we were traveling
together you know we were taking the
same flight
but we weren't staying together it's not
like spring break or sharing was this
guy single
um did this guy like you no definitely
didn't like me i don't remember at the
time because he's married now but i
don't remember at the time if he was
single or i don't remember
but neither it's neither here nor there
really
but um so i don't know with a loose
cannon on your hands yeah it's there
it's there lady i'll tell you that so i
had my
my like look because i like spent more
nights at his house than i spent at my
own
right so like my luggage was there with
my clothes packed for the trip
and he went through my luggage and i
don't know if you guys know about this
but like
you know there's like button-down shirts
and then through your luggage yeah
that's not the end of it don't act like
you haven't done anything crazy big guys
i've gone through the garbage what do
you mean gone through the luggage in the
hotel room
so uh so it was that like a button-down
a long-sleeve button-down shirt
but with like you know like um like a
onesie snap like a bodysuit snap at the
bottom so that it doesn't untuck
okay so i had a few of those but i love
them but that bottom piece is like
lace and he saw yeah i was just taking a
hard left yeah
i mean it's a button-down shirt it's a
button-down shirt
no it ain't with ladies with places with
lace panties what are you talking about
yeah i mean no one sees that part
yeah not unless you want them to
gotta show them the goods you know what
i mean well i know i see with this i
would i would
i wouldn't let you go i would have been
losing it i would have been losing this
guy sounds like a good guy can we get
him in here
i wouldn't let you out of the apartment
let me tell you something kevin uh ralph
tried that because to get him in
he was on he was on an episode of my
podcast so you can go back and watch it
if you'd like and uh
use promo code ayg you can uh
you can watch him win over everybody in
the studio yeah
including me yeah he had everybody on
his side and then stood me up
so he's full of [ __ ] wait stood you up
for what after because you decided to
reconcile yourself
ralph was like you guys obviously still
love each other he claims the reason
that we're not together is because i
didn't have enough time in my schedule
which is not the truth
and uh and so ralph was like why don't
you guys a plan to have one date a week
for a month and then we'll come back and
discuss it
and then that's a sharp guy man the day
that we were supposed to have that date
he just stopped answering my text and it
didn't happen wow
well maybe he was trying to deal with
some emotions that he can't process
no he's just he's just no he's got a
crush on this guy
you don't know him the way i know
shannon okay if you did you would
understand
maybe you're right please call me oh man
all right so
back to the luggage yeah so um so and
wait you talked about this incident on
ralph's podcast um no i think i've
talked about this okay maybe
no but you know what i'm so stupid
because i was focusing on other things
that happened in our relationship
that i didn't even bring up this
situation when he was on the show so
we have an exclusive
because i would love this just in
crotchless panties
i would love to see his nightmare
continues
i would love to hear him try to explain
this away in some way he got jealous
what are you i'm going on a [ __ ]
business trip
to do well we understand where he's
coming i mean we're not saying it's
right
again anything but a pair of boxers and
a t-shirt i'm losing it i'm saying that
right now
all right so he goes through he finds
the yeah
and he got a nice button-up shirt was it
at the bottom of the luggage too
no it was that's i've had pants dress
pants
shoes and button-down shirts okay that
was what i packed
and it was only going for like two days
anyway so he cut up all the clothes in
my luggage
for the trip what cut them up wait did
he put it back in
well he didn't he before i got home
before i got back to his house he was
like
uh we should talk before you come home
because i guess he had a fit of rage and
then came down from it and was like oh
[ __ ] how am i gonna explain this
and so then he told me and i was like
heck the night before what's going on
here
you were at work where were you leaving
the next day yeah yeah i packed left
right there
went to work and i was gonna you know
just so everything's ready and good to
go it's pretty organized
and uh yeah so hey listen sham we need
to talk uh
i accidentally somebody put the
lawnmower on top of your luggage and
everything got cut i don't know what the
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] landscape but it's gonna be
the last time i use them i'm telling you
that much caught a super we got rats
all right we got rats in here call them
so uh so he didn't confront you first he
did that that's what he did
that's a next level crazy yeah and then
so yeah i get it i mean hey i've been
jealous i've been in jealous rages why
are all the clothes why not just one
that that item you know what i mean
sweatshirt yeah it was several articles
of clothing so i didn't end up going
back there before i went on my trip i
went to like low men's on the corner by
my job bought a couple of outfits
and then went and when i came back i
just like wait was there a conversation
that night when you got home i'm sorry
i i didn't go back because i'm like oh
cause he told you on the phone yeah i
cut all your [ __ ] up yeah he's trying to
prepare me before i actually saw it
get ahead of it i get that so you went
and bought [ __ ] like clothes
yeah that's like julia roberts [ __ ]
right there holy can't go back to the
house
[ __ ] buys a red wig gets on a [ __ ]
red eye out of somewhere i don't know
they got big glasses on
one of them scores
holy [ __ ] yeah i know he didn't use
scissors to cut them up either and
i think he did i don't know he used his
government-issued knife that the [ __ ]
that rikers gave him uh so yeah so
it was it was over it was over after
that at least like officially over
we've tried a few times throughout the
years but yeah it was official that's
what broke it up yep
did you have a conversation about it or
just never talked and went back we tried
to talk about it but he
didn't say like why'd you have this in
there what's the deal with you in this
guy
no he was just he he wouldn't even admit
that he was jealous
like he was just trying to skirt around
it like it happened let's move on and
just wouldn't even have a conversation
about it
and i get that you can't get past that
down
[Laughter]
i'm sorry buddy she's [ __ ] i don't
know what to do with her she's a handful
forget about it there you go that was
beautiful
holy [ __ ] damn hey guys what's up let's
take a second to talk about our brand
new sponsor that's ipvanish baby
ipvanish is an incredibly important tool
that helps you protect
your privacy online now listen you know
we're all family here
i don't know how you spend your time
online nor do i care
what you do online isn't my business and
listen
what i do online ain't yours
peaky peaky keep your eyes on your own
page kids
no need to see what uncle hank's doing
back here keep your hands on ten
and two all right if you don't want
cyber criminals to steal your data or
marketers to track what you're buying
you need
ipvanish everybody's doing these are so
important nowadays because everybody's
spending all day online
ipvanish is a vpn or virtual private
network that creates a private
connection from your computer
your phone or tablet to the internet
which protects your identity and
encrypts your data
you know what i mean keep these fools
guessing keep them on their toes
vpns are great for protecting your data
from hackers especially when you're
using a public wi-fi that isn't secure
so if you're at
a starbucks or whatever and you sign in
you know what i mean you can't let you
can't let the feds come
pounding on it they're getting in there
those marketers are hacking you finding
out what you like what you do what you
see what you watch
so with ipvanish your real ip address
disappears
so you can't be tracked online you have
fast unrestricted internet ipvanish
has more than 1500 servers in 70
countries
that's something else so with ipvanish
you're never going to get stuck with a
slow sight or video that doesn't load it
keeps it moving as we like to say
but what really makes ipvanish great is
it's the only vpn with
24 7 customer support bottom line a vpn
is something everyone's going to be
using soon enough
so check out ipvanish to start
protecting your data and privacy online
moving forward
your online data and privacy is going to
be the most important thing
ever so get on board now and plans start
at just
cents per month by going to ipvanish.com
garbage that's 75 off the regular place
just by going to ipvanish.com
garbage start protecting yourself online
with ipvanish today
now back today's show yes sir
all right as a formality unfortunately
we need to do some questions called are
you garbage
um man i love that that's that's [ __ ]
that's
that was a steamy did you ever later
hook up with that guy from work for
never mind jennifer the light of my
swear to god okay on my eyes never
never on my eyes what a guinea thing i
swear on my eyesight the [ __ ] may the
lord take my sight right now do you have
pictures of people you don't like in
your freezer that is [ __ ] that's
old-school
[ __ ] i swear on my eyes from bensonhurst
for me and you are
that's insane i swear in my eyes look at
me she spits on the floor
have you ever been on the floor inside
of a house no have you been in a lot of
fights
no have you been in any fights yes yeah
it wasn't my fault though yeah i can
tell i put hands on it
have you ever punched a guy no no not
out of like sparring
in like a class no okay okay never i'm
not that i'm not that type of girl that
is like
trying to hit a guy to see what he's
going to do back to me because i'm very
well aware of what they can do
yeah i don't need to test them so no
that's not me
gotcha what was the last fight you got
it and why
um like a physical fight you mean so i
mean the only fight the only like real
fight i've ever been in i was like 16.
okay that's yeah yeah and it was a girl
teenage boy yeah and it was a girl that
just like hated me and she was bullying
me all the time and i was in this
program in school called mediation
it's like i was very much a pacifist and
just felt like we talked through
everything
so this girl came and met me after i
left work one night and with her group
of friends and i'm with my group of
friends she's like i don't like you
that and i'm like okay cool like are we
good now then because we don't have to
be friends but
you know there's no point in going any
further with this and she's like and
she's like flipping out so i turned
around and walked away i'm an idiot for
turning around and she like bum rushed
me from behind
and then so we like tussled i like broke
some nails whatever and then our friends
broke it up that was it
that's my only for real fight wow it's
like [ __ ] west side story
was that in front of a diner or
something like that where was that on a
corner up the block from my house
[Laughter]
you can hear singing throughout the
neighborhood
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this is a wacky one
all right let's do a little are you
garbage here all right um
where do we go from here
okay i think i have one what do you got
buddy um
in your shower is there a lot of uh
empty shampoo and conditioner bottles
no i've been victim of that interesting
what kind of hand soap do you currently
use it's probably nice so i have
i have two different ones next to like
my bathroom sink i have a
a uni unicorn one from bath and body
works it's like a little unicorn it's
all sparkly
and then i have like a dial
antibacterial like hard
is it the gold stuff nothing smells
better than that gold
patio that'll take you right back and
you're and you're adamant and saying
you're not garbage now
right like i imagine we ask you routine
questions you know is the apartment
clean this stuff the other thing
we're checking all those boxes probably
probably yeah you yell your co-workers
of course yeah do you yell at dylan they
make me um
do you brush your teeth in the shower
never never
never done that interesting because it's
you're gonna you're using warm water
that's gross that's weird i never
thought of the water
temperature oh yeah you got to get a
nice [ __ ]
cold [ __ ] shotgun i like it hot
sometimes to be honest with you it's
kind of it feels like you went to the
dentist
aren't you not supposed to use warm
water in your mouth like when you're
brushing your teeth i mean you think
he's concerned about the [ __ ] water
temperature he just told us last episode
he
he cleans the public toilets with water
from the toilet bowl who would i ask
that question too anyway
dennis google [ __ ] google without
true yeah google it
that's true you work at a kiosk at a
mall no
you have anything that's airbrushed ever
or now okay uh i have yeah i
actually my first beeper because i'm 750
years old
i had a paper too my beeper was neon
pink and it had airbrushed like a palm
tree
ah you know like that do you know that
or however we're gonna get do you have
stuffed animals in your house now
i have um i have one like a little gizmo
stuffed animal that my dad gave me as a
kid is it on your bed
uh no okay it's in my second room all
right with a knife through its head
have you ever had a birthday party at
chunky cheese
i i i'm pretty sure i did it's out of my
memory but i i remember chuck e cheese
as a kid so i'm pretty sure i did yeah
those places were [ __ ]
disgusting is that does that make is
that like
it's trash it's like it's yeah it's not
not it's not good it's not a good yeah
we're just trying to get a temperature
there's way
chucky cheese is going to pull you out
of the fire now chuck e cheese can't
help you
this is way worse than chuck e cheese of
course of course we did mcdonald's when
i was really young it was mcdonald's
because it's better than the backyard
no i say goldberg yeah it's classy
chuck e cheese you pay like the six
bucks a kid and they run around [ __ ]
in dirty
okay i remember being those mcdonald's
thinking it was weird because it was
like on that wednesday morning and you
could still smoke in there so it was
like one or two customers and we were
looking like a back corner was it before
a play place
yes oh that's an hour that's a real bad
if you're having your yours
it was you're having your birthday party
at a non-play place mcdonald's oh yeah
this is early 80s
there was some bozo dressed up like
ronald mcdonald and they threw this
[ __ ] shitty sheet cake at you
no ball pit no that was before before
any jungle gyms or anything remember how
hot members
i've never been in a ball pit that's how
[ __ ] trashy i'm sad for you
that's how trashy and old i am i missed
the whole ball pit oh i was a big bp kid
big probably eating them find a chicken
nugget in there
i was always scared of them too that's
how trashy i am i thought i would drown
in it
has anyone ever died in a ball pit i
think so what you can breathe still
even if you're covered i don't know what
trust you're not trusting the mcdonald's
corporation to take care of my safety
although i did have a double cheese
today extraordinary today no pickles no
ketchup this guy i mean
adam actually we gotta do something we
gotta get vecchio that's the foley right
there i should get a [ __ ] contract
with mcdonald's
double cheeseburger no pickles no
ketchup extra onions and mac sauce
you look like i'm listening to you like
oh wait say that one more time can we
write that down on the booth
i tell you what fat kid
there it is do you collect anything
okay i collect um like
rocks like gems like crystals yeah
do you go to mediums no
have your cards read i i have but it's
all kind of part of like my show like
the paranormal segment
i'm always just trying to be pru like i
want proof
that anything paranormal exists so i
test them out
okay i've never really received anything
that was true
you know so yeah so i have but it's
never really worked
crystals when was the last time you were
at a flea market or a garage sale
i was i went to uh my i think i was with
my sister maybe last year
and she was like oh let's check this out
and pull over my aunt is also very big
into garage sales and stuff like that
i not for myself okay all right i don't
want a haunted item
okay wacko that's why
no i don't i don't want a napkin holder
that's gonna kill me in the middle of
the night
meanwhile you're sleeping next to tony
colon yeah i can [ __ ] lose it at any
moment i wouldn't be worried about the
[ __ ] i don't want my
ghost in the kitchen i don't want my
recliner to eat me
ah the gizmo with a knife through
something else
that was that was okay i'll tell you
that
oh we're having fun over here these are
the last two episodes have been my
favorite oh that's story man
all right um
i'll do i was in the suburbs with my uh
with my lady a couple of weeks ago and
we saw a garage
moving sale or it really depends on how
you market it a garage sale i don't
really want anything from
would you do a yard sale like go around
the burbs
if if maybe i see like the thing that i
need
actually i meant to tell you kevin that
i saw your post on facebook looking for
an air fryer i have a brand new i mean a
regular deep fryer yeah
i have a brand new deep fryer in a box
yeah do you have a deep fryer
deep fryer if you're trying to make the
sale on the air oh yeah that's a that's
a private message
did you make a facebook a facebook post
to sell that
no you're trying to sell it on
marketplace i keep meaning to i keep
meaning to
and i haven't done it it's still just
sitting there how do you get did
somebody come pick that [ __ ] up yeah man
my family got big into it during
quarantine they're like you can get this
on market i'm like you're buying [ __ ]
off people what are we doing we're in
the middle of a pandemic going to
people's houses and buying you [ __ ]
i've sold stuff on marketplace it's
pretty cool
what have you sold on there i am i had
like an extra coffee table when i moved
apartments there was one already there
so i sold the one i had previously
and an entertainment center turned sage
over the one that was there to cleanse
it you know what you had an
entertainment center you had an action
had an extra coffee table and extra
entertainment entertainment center
do you have an entertainment center in
your home right now yeah what like
because there was stuff left in the
apartment when i moved what's this
entertainment center hold on
hold on i got it i got it big man
stand down stand by all right i'm proud
boy go to our audio visual
what uh let's just loosely you know get
into this what
what how what does this entertainment
center
is there is there a cabinet involved yes
there's doors and drawers yeah what's in
them
uh right so the one i currently have in
my house um
it's it there's on the outside of it is
like candles
pictures of my friends and then i have
like my my uh
my cable box i have an xbox okay um like
remote controls i don't use a lot are in
one of the cabinets batteries are in
other cabinets that's it
do you have any uh chests or dvds in
there no
is there a stereo system no okay there
was it's just
it's just a tv yeah all right all right
i thought you had like subwoofers
speakers going by there was behind the
couch there was when i moved in
and that was some of the stuff that i
got rid of it was there when i moved in
you
you got this place furnished there was
some because it's through somebody that
i know
so there they like stuff they didn't
want they left it like if you want it
take it if not
which is a trash move on their part next
level trash
oh you can leave it if you don't want it
it's like i'm not doing your [ __ ] job
all of a sudden
but you kept it or you got rid of it
right there i kept one i kept one tv
and i got rid of everything how many tvs
are in your house right now
um three do you eat dinner in front of
the tv
yeah okay on a tv tray no
okay no i just like sit on my couch by
my coffee table okay
growing up would you when you were
having family dinner would it be in
front of like would you eat in front of
the tv or just sit down turn the tv off
and sit around the
sit around the table was that very
structured i think we ate in front of
the tv
yeah i think yeah they had family ties
right there
at the table that's great that's [ __ ]
80s all the way up i think that there
were
periods of time where they're like oh
let's pay more attention to the family
and
spend like one night where we all sit at
the kitchen table so we did that
sometimes did you do sunday night
dinners at
grandma's house yeah at grandma's house
it starts at like noon or whatever three
at three
yeah i never understood that finish this
on tuesdays my italian friends were like
yeah i can't hang out today i got dinner
i'm like
it's [ __ ] new dude what do you mean
you got dinner [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] is
that
it's 9 30. yeah i'm asking if you want
to go get a [ __ ] bacon egg and cheese
i got an orange juice in my hand what
are you talking about holy [ __ ]
all right okay that's very very
interesting
are you and i see you're vegan now yeah
and how long has that been going on um
i've been vegetarian for a year and
vegan for eight months okay
hmm i mean we've proven she's trash i
can ask her if before she was vegan
did you use miracle whip or hellman's
mayonnaise helmets
okay so that's classy right yeah yeah i
never saw a miracle whip in the house
were you a butter or margarine family
butter okay
leave it on the counter and put it in
the fridge in the fridge okay
which i listen i'm not gonna lie which i
was a big fridge guy growing up with the
uh the butter and
i've recently changed my ways and
realized that you know on the counter is
nice
and respectable and kind of classy in
certain circles
and i've been looking i've been kicking
around at some [ __ ] butter containers
i might start doing it
does it get too soft that way too soft
butter what are you talking about it's
impossible
it doesn't like but like melty no the
salt keeps it together it just [ __ ]
holds it tight i don't know i've never
done it before but i'm curious it's like
icing it's the best thing
yeah you always over indulged though
[ __ ] schmearing english muffins
schmearing
schmearing think cream hey jacob relax
will you
what do you call jacob wow this first
jewish name i could think of
schmearing oh my all right what was the
first concert you went to
okay the first oh boy it's gonna be bad
i wasn't allowed to go to concerts like
as a kid
and then i work i used to work at
hammerstein ballroom because i'm a
bartender on the side
i worked at hammerstein baldwin so i saw
a lot of shows there but still had never
gone to one
the first official concert i went to was
like six years ago
and it was um with my aunt though she
brought me
just a disclaimer it was a kid rock
and i almost got it we almost got into a
fight there actually oh with each other
or other no with other people is this
all scripted
what's going on this is jesus christ the
casting directors on the phone
i only went because i think it was it
was either reo speedwagon or foreign
i'd rather see kid rocked an reo [ __ ]
speedwagon but that's the kind of music
you're into you were into
like rock classic rock no personally
like i've
the most of the concerts i've been to
i've seen them both eight times
it's i'm not going to say the names
you're not going to know who they are
but like singer songwriters
okay like i like a person on stage with
an acoustic guitar and that's it
who are they plug them who is it um
edwin mccain who you'll know from the
song i'll be
from the 2000s like it's everyone's
wedding song and then amos lee which you
might know from his remake of sweet pea
yeah i know i know the name amos lee
yeah yeah he's yeah he's making okay
yeah that's good that's classy going to
like i see a small singer songwriter is
nice
these are these aunts are viewers yeah
how many do you have
um uh well one that's like really around
and it's my uncle's wife
okay on my dad's side do you call that
aunt by her real name or does she have a
nickname
so no bonnie no and i don't call her
aunt
somebody has a bunny yeah i don't i
don't call her aunt because she came
into my life like a little bit
late so i call her just by her first
name
i have there's like a trashy or a
classier what do you think it depends
um yeah it depends that's probably fine
if it's okay
i call every aunt and uncle i do accept
accept her but only because like she
came in my life later
but there are a lot of weird nicknames
because like what they like
rock come on with all the old school
like guinea names
what do you got so my aunt uh her name
was vincenza
and it was aunt shirley i don't i don't
even remember why yeah
and then um my grandmother's name is
gassamina and she goes by mei
gassamina yeah wow he's a real [ __ ]
old school my uncle i'm trying to think
of what his original name was we call
him uncle
i'm sonny to think i want to it's not i
want to say vincenzo but i i can't
remember
it's been so can't remember your uncle's
real name he's he's been like dead for a
long time
yeah oh okay yeah otherwise he's not
really rest in peace uncle sonny
yeah i had a it's fun my family i have
like 30 or i don't even know how many
cousins we have but my one one of the
older cousins
of the crew uh i guess one day decided
like i'm done with the aunts and uncles
thing and it's like a real prideful it's
like a real respect
thing in your family i'm surprised you
don't go all the way down the line we
were
your parents didn't make you we were at
uh
thanks for something and he's like
talking to my uncle john he's like yeah
that's a good point john and it was like
a record stop there was like what the
[ __ ] did you just do
it was like dude and that was maybe 20
years ago and people still
[ __ ] break his balls again you know i
see that on television a lot that
whenever there's an answer and uncle
they don't use that
like more recently and that is weird to
me i think it might be it might be
phasing out a little bit
everything's aunt and uncle no i think i
think that's important for the family
unit and i thought that was something my
parents did it didn't even matter it
could be they could be dating the guy
i'm
dating the lady and i'm calling her
[ __ ] aunt whatever you know what i
mean
your audience and uncles are still
dating people what the [ __ ] you're 45
years old
no i'm saying when i was a kid they
would they would say hey
if i if i called them by their regular
name one of my parents would stop me and
be like yo
have even if it was some fresh piece
that was coming around not like fresh
fresh not like the first time you show
up to the graduation party but
there's been a couple of christmas
looking stems on blondie huh there's
been a couple christmas presents or
birthday cards exchanged
i think that's really what yeah that's
fair because my wife came in as
yeah my wife came in his aunt yeah but
it also depends on if you're like a
[ __ ] 10 year old calling
you know some chick you just met andre
something's [ __ ] wrong
not up in my house she's giving tubby
time
can and trish tucked me in all right
let's stay on track interesting
what do you got hmm have you ever dated
a guy who sold weed
yes oh how recently like it was just
like kit like
don't you don't get a pin a date on it
or name in my 20s
in your 20s okay i feel that's fair was
it like he was moving weight or nickel
and dimes
it was probably moving weight oh man you
are garbage what do you think she's
[ __ ] hanging out with the street
dealers
i don't know what's worse middle
management no i don't know what's worse
dating a guy who sells dime bags
dana guys are selling [ __ ] cops and
[ __ ] where would you guys go on vacation
as a kid
and where do you go on vacation now um i
don't remember that so when i was like
five we went to disney
in florida florida world yeah
um but i don't i just know from pictures
i don't have any memory
really of that trip five yeah
they start them slow in brooklyn i
remember seeing mary poppins
but i don't know if that's a real memory
or a trump picture from pictures yeah
but um after that i don't think we ever
went anywhere
i don't think we ever went on a vacation
even when the pops was making a little
bit of cash nope
brighton beach breezy point something
like that no and i don't think that our
parents ever took us to the beach like
my
my aunts and uncles would take us to the
beach my sister and i i don't think my
parents ever took us to the beach so
we've broken them [ __ ] is that
brooklyn people it's so city that they
forget that they're like literally a
mile from the ocean
it's like it's like two different worlds
because we'll all go out to like uh
fort tilden and stuff like that like in
the rockaways and it's like you get out
there and you're like it's like in
another another [ __ ] country
that's crazy yeah um
that's nuts then take it to the beach
what would you was there a pool
community pool in the summer
nope no and it was only until like some
of the family members started to move
out to staten island and then they had
pools so we would go there
above ground or in ground pools there
was a mixture
a mixture of the two not like an above
ground pool in staten island
that's clean living right there holy
[ __ ]
one one vacation that when you were five
to disney world yeah
that's that's like oh well we went to
visit my mom
we went to visit my mom's family once in
maine over the summer
that yeah okay and uh it's like real
like me like trailers like they live in
trailers
and they uh my uncle they went to they
went lobstering
and brought lobsters back to the house
and let the kids play with the lobsters
so we named them and everything
and then they go we did that too with
crabs that's real trashy when you're
playing with dinner in the [ __ ]
on the back deck i've played with dinner
before
for sure i did lobsters last last year
we went up to maine and we did lobsters
we mean
some people in the house and we were i
was playing with them i was [ __ ] 33
years old playing
with lobsters in the kitchen just doing
[ __ ] instagram posts with them and
[ __ ]
chasing that that's [ __ ] terrifying
and then you can just eat it after
yeah well first of all it's a crustacean
they don't have central nervous systems
or like brain
you know they're like memories or
anything that's proven isn't it i ain't
got that [ __ ] either
whatever you wouldn't eat me i'm with
you
i don't have to find a pretty big pot
have to
have to put boiling water in your above
ground pool to cook you i
told you i can't do octopus anymore
either plus it's like 40 in apps
you're doing bits over here that was
pre-written
because it bombed no it was yeah it was
if you
thought of that in the moment and it
came off the cuff it would have killed
you're not
you're not a good actor anyway cbd is
kicking in
what are you talking about um all right
i got one have you ever grown up
new york's tough a little bit new york
kids are tough as a teenager do you ever
spend time at like hanging at a gas
station or a 7-eleven like did you have
like a store
convenience store that you would hang
out at like whatever you know yeah there
were two spots one was like this school
um what's this the schoolyard okay we
would hang out it's normally a
normal city but like at night you know
and then uh there was like um
a place like on the avenue where like
trucks
would park but it's like on on the
street it's not like a hidden place
there was just like a few trucks would
park there and we would kind of hang out
behind there
like trailers yeah kinda okay there's
like four of them not a lot and then we
would just like hang out in that area so
we can like drink our 40s like a bunch
of hoodlums
yeah scope out the truck see what's the
carry and maybe call up
yeah well i think i was like it was like
like a rest area trucks no it was
just like kind of like a like a bigger
parking lot like on the regular street
in a place where a store would be
okay yeah there was just like this
parking lot and we were just hanging out
hanging on there yeah
it's always gonna be tough for [ __ ]
new york kids to like
find shelter to smoke and drink and
[ __ ] there's no
you can't do it in the houses because
the house it's all apartments are so
tiny there's no spare space
like i was doing it in like finished
basements and [ __ ] you know what i mean
living the life
you ever get collared you ever get
picked up no no
okay no thankfully and back then it was
i don't know it was such a different
thing back then because there were times
where like friends of mine
were like cops would be like you know
take it somewhere else or whatever and
everyone's like smoking joints and
drinking yeah
he had connections on the force i think
it was just we weren't really causing
trouble but yeah back in the day [ __ ]
was i mean i remember one time we got
pulled over
the driver was you [ __ ] bombed and
there was like six of us in the [ __ ]
pontiac grand dam and
the cop pulled us over in center city
and he's like you guys are clearly
[ __ ]
we're like speeding and like sings out
the window and like it was just like
you're
[ __ ] idiot college kids and he goes
he goes listen my shift is over at three
in the morning when i get he goes this
car better be here i'm coming back at
the end of my shift and if it's not i'm
[ __ ] coming to lock you up all right
he's like parked the car [ __ ] go home
come get it in the morning old school
yeah man oh man
uh i assume growing up in bensonhurst an
italian family
you weren't [ __ ] with like fast food
a lot right or were you no
okay no it would be like a special thing
where if we would like go to
go to mcdonald's or something you know
but yeah
it wasn't a lot uh this is a big one on
the show
uh in new york we know what was the
grocery store
you went to growing up so i actually
couldn't remember the name of it and
last night
i put a facebook post up because a lot
of people that live in my neighborhood
are on facebook
and i asked them and i found it out and
it was called super duper
oh that is super duper tree
stereos too super duper stereo and lunch
meat
this sunday
[Laughter]
yeah it wasn't a chain it was just like
a mom-and-pop super duper i didn't think
it was franchise yeah they definitely
didn't have a marketing
department either super duper
later to become that food it is now met
food what is that food any good the [ __ ]
is that
that sounds like they sell life
insurance met food is it's
real cheap yeah yeah what do you go to
now
so actually that's the only because i
don't drive because i'm from new york
you do you have a license i have a
license okay what was the last time you
driven
when i passed my road test when i was 23
i'm 38.
oh my god jesus that's crazy
would you be nervous to drive a car
you're terrified if i don't i'm not sure
which is the gas and which is the break
yeah let's lay off that yeah i'll get
you an uber home all right
um wait what was the question uh where
do you shop now yeah so it's there's a
met food with walking distance
to my house and then so if i need
something quick that's where i'll go
otherwise i just order my groceries from
instacart
it's a cartoon i thank you for like a
trader joe's whole foods so
sometimes they do whole foods through
amazon yeah i just discovered that over
the quarantine
yeah it's nice if you have prime it's
like
free delivery and yeah within four hours
yeah it's freaking amazing
yeah interesting sometimes like
the guy's like yeah we can deliver he's
like you know we can deliver this to you
and like before you get home it'll be
there i don't
i felt so stupid and antiquated i'm like
what am i the only [ __ ] still food
shopping here yeah
i do but i'll tell you what i'm too too
crazy or too fat or two whatever i i
don't trust that at all i wanted to
go to the grocery store myself get your
hands on the goods yeah i don't want you
picking out my [ __ ] box of fruity
pebbles i don't know why i just don't
aside from produce where like you want
to look at the fruit or the vegetables
that you buy
if you're just getting stuff in boxes
and stuff it why does everybody like the
chicken i don't know what they're doing
to it on the way over there
you know some dirt bag think of raw
chicken you order delivery food all the
time sure but that's cooked
okay i got one what was the last i got
two what was the last meal you cooked
um i mean it's stupid vegan [ __ ] now
okay it would be like quinoa and
vegetable
you know it's just yeah it's not it's
just eat vegan frozen dinners because
they're pretty garbage
i have i've had like a vegan frozen
pizza man that's
just eat a [ __ ] pizza what are we
doing there's a really good one from
whole foods
it was a really good one the vegan
thing's really pulling me out of the
fire here
yeah because that's tough it's it's like
it really prevents you from being
way more garbage it's like you build a
[ __ ] a a wall that we can't get above
but the met road place or whatever it is
super duper come on out and meet the men
it's just a big minute
i would have stuck with super duper
that's better no that's where it was
when i when i lived there it was super
duper
i got one for you uh do you sneak snacks
into the movie theater when you do go to
the movie theater
um no i think i've snuck alcohol in
before though
i respect that yeah in a water bottle
fast and loose
did we ask you brushing the teeth we did
yeah she said no remember you have to
google about the temperature of the
water later that's right okay
um it's cold cold's better yeah for sure
that was our voice from the ada um
surgeon general coming in hot and i love
it
let's do you want to do the big one that
we've been talking
let's do it yeah all right since you
didn't ask the way i
asked the previous question okay
it's been a thing last week kevin
dropped a bombshell all right i've known
this guy 12 years
and all of a sudden out of nowhere he
asks if
did you take leftovers home and it turns
out that kevin thinks it's trashy to
take
leftovers and doesn't under any
circumstances
take leftovers from a restaurant how do
you shannon lee
feel about that statement yeah but talk
about leading the [ __ ] witness
i'm sorry not more yeah i asked becky
owen do you take a doggy bag and you're
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] losing doggy all
right here's the story this piece of
[ __ ] over here
[ __ ] [ __ ] what do you think
about leftovers call your ex-boyfriend a
[ __ ] punch him in a head
would i have any shot fighting this guy
no all right fair enough no this one's a
this one's a rough one
all of them actually they're all pretty
rough but he beat up me and foley
probably probably i mean it's only
because like if you [ __ ] throw a
chicken nugget at you you'll be
distracted
i'll be blowing the guy what are you
talking about
you're gorgeous did he come here often
what kind of car did he drive
how about that uh at the time we started
dating it was a
knight rider what's it a ford charger
what makes charger dodge
dodge charger
fireman car because they make they make
a [ __ ] coin don't run your mouth to
anybody drive one of those at a red
light
or like that or like one of like the
explorers that's like kind of like matte
black and they got like
a jeep yeah they they but they decked
the jeeps out you see one of them
because i live by a police station dude
it looks like a [ __ ] looks like a
ford parking lot oh
a jeep one of those gas tanks in the
back they're scary oh yeah what he has
done to his jeep now
embarrasses me that he puts that much
energy and thought into his car
like there's like there's like a
community of jeep oh jeep that's a thing
it's a jeep
and they have a secret weight they have
a secret wave remember the first time my
buddy did that [ __ ] in a jeep i was
like what tv
[ __ ] pull over let me out of here
i kind of get it i mean it's got to be a
thing because gp they do it you know
what i mean my brother got a jeep and
just started doing it's the weirdest ah
it's [ __ ] lame i got a mercury
montego 2005.
give each other the finger it's just
changing
this car it's made a bunch of old people
[Laughter]
maury um so do you all right back back
on track
leftovers do you take them or not yeah
oh i take them because usually it's like
i don't know i don't like to eat like a
tremendous amount of food in one shot
okay so let's say i get classy
explanation
let's say i get halfway through it i
don't want to waste
all of this food so i'll take it home
and then there's like a 50 50 chance if
i eat it later that night
then that's the thing if i don't eat it
late at that later that night it'll sit
in my fridge for like three days then
i'll end up throwing it out
okay because it's trash you'll end up
just throwing out trash
that you should have thrown out [ __ ]
three days ago thank you very much
what are you doing wait dylan you're
you're an anti-leftover too
so the one part of the argument i think
everyone forgets with
kippy's is the idea to go to a
restaurant this is where he won me over
you go to a restaurant you spend the
money
you i want to just get up and leave
that's an experience yeah then you're
also the [ __ ] like carrying a bag
around or whatever like
it doesn't make so you are you're an
anti-leftover
wow um okay with it my thing too it's
like everybody got mad at me like dude
it's [ __ ] if you take a half a burger
and you put it on the [ __ ] thing it's
so f
i'm not saying you don't find it good
that is not what i'm saying
there's a difference between good and
[ __ ] close it's great i think it's
heroin is good people do heroin and
they're trash
if you're eating you're eating literal
trash
that if you they're going we're going to
throw this out and trashes and
we're going to throw this away if you
don't want to take it home and if you
want to take garbage home and eat it if
not we'll throw it away i have a
question
yes are you also against leftovers at
home
no it's very different what the [ __ ]
that's also trash
wow no it's not it's that one because
one because
just [ __ ] blew you you don't think
you don't think i got it
this guy's a fraud he's a [ __ ] fraud
you don't think i got a [ __ ]
reasoning for that i made it this far in
a business
what i'm thinking about that you use
restaurant to go containers
you wrap it up in a bag and put it in
can you wrap this up for me
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna take this
to the fridge um no when you cook you
don't cook
when you order you order one portion for
yourself regardless of the size of that
portion
it's a portion you're not cooking three
pieces of chicken or whatever like
you know you never just cook one portion
of food for yourself i do you're cooking
that yeah that's not necessarily true
okay but oh yeah
okay but if i okay so let's put it this
way if i made one chicken breast
if you're making let me see if you're
making more than you're gonna eat you're
looking for leftovers i got news for you
buddy you're a leftover i'm not going to
make
one serving size of pasta i'm going to
make a thing of pasta that's completely
[ __ ] different
and if you can't wrap your dumb head
around that that's insane
i'd be so pissed if somebody made a
single portion in your body yeah of
course that's why but if you make
[ __ ] if i do make one piece of chicken
right and
[ __ ] nine string beans and at the end
of that there's one bite of chicken and
two string bangs left
i'm not putting that in the fridge i'm
throwing that away it's not enough for
another meal
half a cutlet when you order something
at a restaurant it's a big
most of the time it's a pretty big
portion for sure yeah so if you have a
significant amount left i feel like as
long as it's enough where you can have
another meal out of it
then it's okay to save it you know i
just disagree
it's just terrifying i think it's a part
of the experience i love the idea of
leftovers you're garbage
what is this you are trash the idea that
it's not the idea that you
like it you also like it's you also
clean the [ __ ] toilet bowl
with toilet bowl you clean the toilet
the second time you mentioned that today
on this broadcast
but like you're trash just because
you're like cheeseburgers
yeah it doesn't mean the thing is not
trash it's trash
is it enjoyable for a lot of people sure
but it's [ __ ] i like i said i eat micro
i mean
microwaves hot dogs what if it's shaped
like a swan that's a little different i
gotta give you that lobster thermador
come on
and a lot of people say they take uh
they take it over their dog or
or a homeless person or a person on the
street which is very respectable i ain't
giving my dog lobster i'll tell you that
you can't afford lobster
wow what an episode this has been uh
great what are we thinking here
is there like a like a meter a
percentage sometimes we'll give out a
percentage i
you're a royalty i would like a
percentage yeah i mean
uh the [ __ ] dating juice heads who
were [ __ ] cracking skulls in staten
island ain't helping you sweetheart but
if we had to do a number of percent i
would say 80 percent
trash yes of course yeah because now you
know you're doing
you know you're different yeah i would i
would say in the 70s or 80s for sure i
mean
the fact that you're vegan pulls you out
a lot of a bad pulls you out of a lot of
bad possibilities yeah that really just
you know kind of stops the conversation
there
because that's a classic thing you know
whatever um or at least prevent you from
being more garbage
but you came up you had like a good
upbringing you know what i mean parents
stayed together
[ __ ] you know good neighborhood
school everything like that it seems
that's all good like you're not from
trash right
right yeah but somewhere along the way
you got a little you know
rough around the edges and the way you
find the way you
revel in your [ __ ] gorilla boyfriends
beating people up
is insane john you've cleaned blood off
dude
[ __ ] loafers before you know these
are your new aldos
one of my exes when i used to he used to
bounce at the bar that i bartended
he came in from a fight and i had to
like disinfect his knuckles with vodka
i mean if you're unless you're unless
you're no you didn't swear to god
no no you didn't have to use vodka yeah
it's but
it betters the story i'm sure it was our
first [ __ ] aid kit in that place yeah
pour a little pop off you could have got
some hydrogen peroxide
it wasn't it's not as sexy as a bottle
of grey goose
top shelf get the goose babe you don't
only touch belvedere goose
he definitely had a smoke in the other
hand too smoking while you're patching
him up you probably did
you ever give stitches to anybody no
what's your [ __ ] mom doctor
not that part jeffrey do you ever dig a
bullet on anybody's heart
you [ __ ] wacko
i mean this has been fan [ __ ] this
has been one of my favorite episodes as
well
yay holy [ __ ] couple of hot ones coming
at you gang that was [ __ ]
fun she's a murderer what would you like
the folks out there to know
um i um that i'm trying to do better
no i don't mean that i know we should
have the redemption
garbage redemption moment also write in
it maybe shannon will take you out on a
date have you been maybe right in with
the leg
show a picture of the last guy you beat
up
[Laughter]
and maybe just maybe you can take
shannon out and take leftovers
or show you show your knuckles after
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's fine
um listen to my podcast the thing is we
talk about bad dates fighting and ghosts
and um
both of the hosts have been on the show
yeah we've done it it's a fantastic show
it's on the gas digital network check it
out
yeah it's awesome yep and uh follow me
on instagram it's shannon lee 6982
that's it
thank you so much this was amazing kippy
what do you got the folks out there
to know as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube subscribe
there as well those numbers are [ __ ]
through the roof we appreciate it uh
well over 6 000 subscribers at this
point
also um oh i forgot to plug this last
time there's very active facebook
groups reddit subreddits are [ __ ]
awesome and a discord which i'm not
really sure what it is but the kids are
on it they invite it to me i
pop in every now and then uh so check
those out we appreciate that and
i catch the facebook post they kill me
yeah i mean it's like people are posted
there's like 50 posts a day we're all
very active we're all on the same page
it's so funny
yeah all in the yeah like this was i
mean
so yeah this was awesome this was great
so check it out everybody thank you so
much i'm at cameron comedy on all social
media you can follow me there uh we're
po you know we post clips of the show
and other funny stuff that of garbage
things that i do
yes sir guys again thank you so much we
love you and we will see you
next week peace peace